attendre un
jour plus temporaire
[Musique]
ordinateur
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
volume [Musique
]
étranger [Musique
] [
Musique]
Jesse Batman
[Musique]
étranger
Je suis Star-Lord
J'ai formé les Gardiens
rencontré un  fille est tombée amoureuse
cette fille est morte mais ensuite elle est revenue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] est
revenue une [ __ ] totale oh s'il vous plaît
il a laissé de côté des informations importantes
mais
c'est l'essentiel
[Musique]
ma mission sacrée
est de créer la société parfaite
et je veux que les choses soient parfaites
[Musique]
détesté les choses hé elles sont
euh je veux que vous sachiez tous que je suis
reconnaissant de me battre aux côtés de mes amis
les incinérer
[Musique]
étranger
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à ce que nous nous trouvions
êtes-vous prêt
pour Un  Last Ride
[Music]
[Applaudissements]
nous nous envolerons tous ensemble
dans l'éternité
[Music]
et le beau ciel
[Applaudissements]
qui que ce soit dont tu étais amoureux
ça ressemble plus à elle le sien ne
m'amène pas en eux
frappe-le  de ce que
nous avons remarqué à quel point tes yeux étaient noirs
ils ont été remplacés par mon père comme
méthode de torture il a choisi un joli
ensemble
ici je viens parce que je suis prêt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je suis prêt
étranger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
ce n'était qu'un rêve le nom du Mirage
allez tuez
tapotez d'accord détendez vous un mirage souvenez vous
[Musique]
Je peux aller à
l'étranger
ce qui se passe
tu as changé  l'avenir
tu as changé le chemin tu
veux de l'aide tu es tu es tu es
ouais
je suis Batman
[Musique]
oh regarde la bande-annonce complète en ligne maintenant
le flash seulement bat le 16 juin
nous sommes trop haut nous ne pouvons pas descendre
d'ici
tu es presque là
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas comme n'importe quel autre visage de fantôme
qu'est-ce que c'est que cet endroit
c'est un sanctuaire
les gars
nous
l'exécutons
allez maman
cri
c'est pour toi
seulement dans les cinémas 10 mars billets en
vente maintenant
[Musique]
65  exclusivement dans les salles de cinéma le 10 mars